Dear man,
I think maybe talking Duany to come to California.
Really?
I Dunno.
I'm got to get them used to that beach life.
Yeah.
I mean he,
so he's been coming down like my fight camp was 10 weeks long from four with him
I was longer,
but with him it was 10 weeks and he was flying out three days a week.
So every Monday he would land,
he would leave Wednesday night.
Wow.
And we train Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday and the hard right.
I make sure to take like Thursday off and then do my other stuff while he's
gone.
But every week he was traveling back and forth and dedication right there.
Dude.
I have a family now,
you know,
like yeah,
he's lived in my house.
Like he's on the meal plans with the cal vetoes,
like he's full bore into it.
Like he gives me is all,
I'm a very fortunate person that I've met Dwayne.
And it's an amazing relationship or relationship.
Yeah.
How close it is.
It really is.
And I mean,
that's the ideal when you can get a mentor in a,
in a,
a student that have that kind of a bond together and you can learn so much.
Yeah.
And he won't let,
like we have such a good bond now too,
that he won't like let bullshit slide won't be pumping me up for no reason.
Right.
You won't like,
let me,
I mean,
I'm not a lazy guy,
but if I was,
he wouldn't let me like miss practice or,
you know,
I mean,
he almost has to pull me back more than anything,
but,
uh,
he gives me this true assessment of what needs to be done.
Um,
I obviously lost the suit pseudo,
we got home and he had sent texts.
Music had come out tomorrow.
I'm gonna work out with a warm,
but I'd love to get some working with you.
We just,
some things we should go over.
I was like,
alright.
Wow.
So like I was working out with him three days after the fight.
What did he say about that exchange?
Um,
he says like,
he,
maybe he needs a change and things on the midst and maybe like,
so for instance,
the whole exchange,
uh,
I think I closed the distance too hard.
Henry Su to switched up who he was as a fighter.
I think he came out differently,
which was great by him.
He's done great things.
He,
um,
I expected him to maybe run a little bit more and he came out aggressive.
Um,
and so getting used to the distance control,
you know,
not always having a set plan and,
and going for those Combos,
what I think's going to happen to be able to adjust on the fly.
And maybe me and him,
sometimes we are too set on certain things rather than um,
reaction type stuff,
you know,
and I need to react to distance change and you'd wrecked the things like that.
It's hard to really change anything on that fight because I didn't get a chance
to see it either.
You know,
it was so,
so quick.
Now do have you talked to Dana or anyone since,
I know you said that you guys would talk in the future,
but it's been about what,
how many days?
It's been about a week or so has been to uh,
about a week and a half.
It's been a week and a half now.
Yeah.
Um,
I haven't heard anything since the,
the day after the fight.
I was texting with them that after the fight and he said they had to sit down
and figure out what the plane is kind of thing,
you know.
Um,
but obviously everyone knows that,
that we want to run it back and it sounds like they do as well too,
so.
Well as far as something that people want to watch,
whether it's at 35 or 25 I think people absolutely would like to see that.
I mean at 35 the big selling point would be Henry gets a chance to become champ
champ.
Of course,
they all fight him at 25,000 for my 35 pound belt on the line.
I really,
it works that way.
I know it doesn't,
but I'm saying like,
if you beat me,
I was like,
I seriously,
like,
I wouldn't even tell him.
I just seriously don't even care.
Like the belts are awesome.
All that stuff in the and recognition,
all that stuff.
But to me,
I'd want that.
I want that one back.
I want that opportunity back to even just show how much work in how smart I was
and how I didn't get,
I didn't get hit and I wasn't fragile from being at 25 I really wasn't like,
it wasn't like,
um,
I didn't get beat because I was a 25 pounder.
I have felt,
I have no excuses.
I got beat because I got beat.
Right.
I have no excuses that I was too fragile at being at one 25 is I felt better
than I've ever felt my entire life.
I just want the chance to prove that.
You know what I mean?
So that's why I say that I would give him my built at 35 beats me at 25 again,
but,
well,
obviously take the fight wherever.
I mean,
I think Ali needed Frazier,
right?
Sugar Ray needed Tommy Hearns.
I mean,
this is just,
this is the nature of the sport and a guy like him.
I mean,
I think you,
you and Cody needed each other.
Yeah.
I think there's something about that kind of intense rivalry that is so
important for,
for,
for actualizing,
for pseudos a motherfucker.
Man,
he's good and he's a,
he's a world is a Olympic gold medalist.
He's a competitor.
He knows what he's doing.
Right.
Let me just,
arguably from his accomplishments is one of the greatest combat sports athletes
of all time.
The first guy ever to be an Olympic gold medalist and a UFC world champion,
which I,
the gold medalist thing.
I even hold even higher for him than even the being like obviously UFC
champions.
Huge,
right?
But I wrestled my whole life.
I grew up wrestling and to be an Olympic gold medalist is a fucking huge thing.
Um,
I still think today wrestling is the hardest sport I've ever done.
And just to see that achievement,
especially young,
he did it at,
that's,
I almost hold that higher than him being a UFC champion.
Well,
also the fact that he was beat by Dj,
he beat by beat by mighty mouse in the first round.
He gets destroyed.
He gets need to the body,
taken out,
beaten up and stopped and humiliated.
Right.
Comes back.
And what was it like two years later?
I think it was deep and beats him.
I mean,
becomes the fucking champion.
Beats the pound for pound consensus.
Best fighter on the planet.
And the guy that had held that title from the very first time it was ever
brought to the UFC,
he's been the only flyweight champion until Henry came along.
So,
and that's another reason why I want that fight,
man.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like I know that I'm better than him.
Obviously you're going to give me,
some people are going to give me shit for saying that because obviously the
fight they failed.
Think he went down the way it went down.
But guess what?
I'm better than that motherfucker and I want to prove it.
I want the toughest fights.
I mean that's why I was calling out Max Holloway.
I want to,
I want to be interviewed.
I want to call Max haul away with Sam Kalvia.
I can be walking around 165 pounds with 6% body fat,
you know 100% like this guy,
man,
he can stack the weight on me.
You can take it off me.
I can go.
I have a secret weapon was Sam cal veto.
I'm telling you and I could've had a secret.
You just,
yeah,
he blurted it out.
But people,
he won't work with everyone.
He won't do it.
Yeah.
If you come to him like unless you fit who we,
he likes.
If he fit his image,
like what does that look like?
We work out of his garage,
which is so crazy.
You know,
like he could have a giant facility with all his hard work and science.
He does,
but he likes the,
the grit of having any just house.
Like he gets home from work,
he's all dressed up in his tie,
sometimes were already there waiting for him and he's doesn't even change.
He's out there throwing medicine balls that are facing his tie and I'll just up
from the soup from work,
you know,
like he likes that shit.
You know,
that's something I might not even be a calculus teacher anymore and just be a
string conditioning coach.
But that's not what he wants.
You know,
he's not in it for the fame and the money.
He's in it for the science and the love of doing it.
I want to see that garage.
You pull it,
pull up his garage because this doesn't,
now I'm thinking about how big my fucking gym out here is.
You couldn't even park two cars in it.
This is,
it's,
it's a small garage.
We have one,
uh,
one squat rack.
We have a spot to do,
like our cleans and our,
um,
dead lifts.
What he really has his,
he has three,
four by,
I don't know,
three bites.
There it is.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So it's a very small two car garage.
Yeah.
That has got filled with a bunch of murderers.
He's got like three bikes and we ride bikes and walking by,
if you were a girl.
Oh Dude,
all the time.
People,
old people walk by all the time.
We're in the garage and I,
I'm yelling when I'm in there working out cause he's pushing like signs.
Our workouts are three hours long,
you know,
and we're going,
there's a park across the street and we're throwing medicine balls at each other
and go to that.
Back to that last one with Pico please.
Yeah.
You get a chance to see what's in the garage.
So I guess he parks his car in the driveway.
Oh yeah,
he doesn't,
he doesn't park.
That's the sanctuary man.
That's crazy.
He's got these stationary bikes in there that where he kills us on.
That's like,
um,
how we push our lactate threshold.
So what does he,
he's doing something with bands right here.
Yeah,
that's true.
A lot of things with bands,
right?
Yeah.
Cause you get the east centric and concentric contraction.
You know,
you have a straight and he's like,
we're just doing it.
There's for your shoulder stability,
you rotator cuffs.
I mean yeah,
with the Jujitsu and the wrestling,
your shoulders take a beating.
Yeah.
And so that's kind of really does strengthen it.
I do a lot of cuff stuff because all the different injuries that I've had.
I do a lot of band stuff with my,
you know,
yep.
This way,
the external rotation,
internal rotation stuff.
Yeah.
Bands are great.
Now,
why bands though as a PR as opposed to cables,
like cables with a stacks.
Wait,
why does you use bands?
By just what's what we have.
I mean,
if he had a nice Kaiser machine in there,
maybe we'd use it.
But I think,
um,
the resistance coming back really,
really wants to support the further you extend a band,
the harder wants to pull you back to where when you have a weight on there,
it's the exact same weight going in and out toward the further you extend that
band,
the harder you make it on yourself.
There's,
I think there's just more you can do with it and it's just very easy and it
takes up no space.
Right,
right.
We do a lot of medicine ball work,
um,
for our core and for our shoulders as well too,
like catching and weird angles with keeping our balance.
Um,
we do like a lot of like kind of like old school shit but in a certain way.
In a certain time.
Yeah.
And so how does he get all that shit into his garage?
Does he have to pull stuff out into the driveway?
There's stuff on the side of his house.
He's got like a little Chessy stack stuff into and um,
man,
we,
a lot of it's,
it doesn't need much.
It really doesn't.
And there's a,
there's a lot of work you can do with just body weight,
but I mean we have a hundred pound medicine balls.
We got these big logs.
He makes it like,
it's almost like a,
the strong man competitions.
There's a big,
there's a big hill next to his house that he makes his carry these like hundred
pound logs and we at the farmer's carry him up the hill and we are doing with a
partner.
And when I get up so far I dropped my run back and get a hundred pound medicine
ball at the sprint up the hill with it.
Things like that where you're pushing your your lactate threshold over time.
Wow.
Yeah.
And how does he schedule The training sessions?
Like how does he know what to have you do?
One off of our timeframe of when we want to peak off of my heart rate
variability and how my body's reacting to our training.
Cause maybe I sparred and I had met too hard with Dwayne,
so I wake up the next morning and he realizes,
oh we've got to pull back today.
Like if I push you hard today,
you're going to go in such a deep hole.
This is going to take you a week to come out of it to where he only wants me to
get to that really high peak,
take a day off so that now I can start coming back up again to where if I just
continue for four or five days,
just crushing it quite as hard as I possibly can.
My body is going to crash so hard.
That's going to take me,
it's going to be more of a detriment to come out of that hole.
Then if I would've just taken a break in between those days,
so he'll,
he'll sketch.
They are,
schedules will change.
We have a,
we have a schedule from the beginning,
so Sam,
12 weeks out.
Like,
all right,
this is our plan so we're going to do,
but then maybe I get sick or maybe I've trained too hard with Dwayne the day
before and so he'll realize all right,
this next day was a little bit easier.
Even if it's my Jujitsu,
he knows I'm going to do to practice.
He's like,
maybe just drill,
you know,
go flip page.
Just make sure it's like a low base drill.
Like don't get your heart rate over such and such,
which I don't roll with the heart rate monitor on,
but I can can kind of just guess.
You know how hard I need to go.
Yeah.
Could you,
I guess you could just,
you buddy,
do you know anybody who does [inaudible] now it seems like it would get knocked
off or something.
I mean,
maybe for drilling.
Yeah.
You know,
so when he's got you doing all this crazy stuff like dead lifts and pliers and
all medicine ball work,
um,
does,
is there like a logic to what exercises are done when and like how does he like,
cause it seems like you're doing all this old school stuff like Badass stuff,
but my question is always like when do you do that?
Yes.
When is that,
when is that done?
Like once a week.
Is that done early in the training camp?
Is it done late?
Like when are you doing strength work and your,
cause you were saying you were doing cleans like the week out.
Only us.
So when I'm doing those like a week I'm doing,
I'm only a certain amount of reps,
um,
you know,
I'm not,
maybe not taxing my body for as long as I would an earlier camp and even though
I'm going heavy,
maybe I'm only doing two sets,
you know,
just to keep my central nervous system strong
other than just taxing yourself,
you know.
Or there's certain times like there are certain days he needs,
I need to get explosive power work.
Or some days I needed you.
Cadence,
fast food,
fast feet,
um,
cardio work and he has that all out on what days or what,
what weeks are what?
Depending on where I'm at,
my fight camp or if I'm going 25 and if I want to stay as strong as it was at
35,
things like that.
Or if I end up going 45,
um,
to be able to keep my,
my,
my cardio up.
Because the thing was if I ever,
if I were to go 45,
I'm gonna have to put so much more muscle on.
The worry is that I'm going to lose cardio.
Right.
And nobody wants to be able to keep that lactate threshold and me keep my cardio
if I'm able to walk around at 165 pounds.
Now,
what other stuff does he have you doing for recovery?
You're doing a sauna work.
Are you doing ice baths?
Like what kind of stuff?
I have an infrared sauna.
I do,
I'm a do red light therapy.
I do.
Um,
uh,
what do you mean by red light therapy?
There's a machine that I have in my house,
it's called a juve.
It's,
I'm a big red light.
It says 680 to 880 nanometer light that I stand in front of it for a certain
amount of time to,
um,
not only increased my testosterone,
but to help recovery in my,
uh,
my mitochondria,
my cells and flushing my body out.
Um,
uh,
what does that thing look like?
Whoa.
Look at that dude.
You're in the future is that,
you know,
[inaudible] there's jacked.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
I have one of those in my garage.
I have a infrared sauna in my garage.
Um,
I do,
how big is that thing?
Is that there's new ones now that are huge.
I get as big as my body.
Um,
they have ones that go in the back of your door.
They have travel ones you can take with you.
That's really small.
The reason why I got into it,
it was for a,
um,
increasing my testosterone and the utility of my sperm Holla.
Yeah.
Cause I was,
I was,
I was having,
um,
my session was low and I wanted to increase it and I saw this,
through Matt Brown,
actually,
Matt Brown is the one that kind of got me this one.
I was out in Colorado,
shout out to the,
he's got some awesome training equipment and shot.
He's,
and he's a very knowledgeable,
very well read guy.
And a,
you wouldn't like pure wouldn't guess that why when I had him on the podcast,
that's one thing a lot of people said they go,
I thought that the guy was a caveman.
Right.
Kind of is.
He's also kind of brilliant.
He wants to be the caveman like manly man.
But he's very smart about it.
Yeah.
Um,
so he's the one that turned me onto that.
And so I got into it and uh,
I want to increase my testosterone but also read about,
um,
increasing motility and my spare time I was trying to have a kid and were having
trouble and this and that.
And it could be,
that could have been my diet.
I switched so much up that I can't tell you which one it was.
You know,
cause Sam helped me out.
This helped me out.
I mean,
so I'm doing that.
I'll do a hyperbaric chamber,
I'll do cryo therapy.
How often do you do the hyperbaric chamber?
Um,
only when I need it because it can mess with your,
um,
your hermatocrit you know,
if I'm going to do a lot of altitude training as well too,
I'm trying to increase my red blood cell count and my hematocrit.
Um,
and then when you go,
when you get into a,
a heartbreak chamber,
you're breathing 100% oxygen.
So if I'm in too much,
so lower my hematic career,
right?
But I do a lot of,
here's the altitude Ms,
same as an altitude machine he has me used is called Alto lab.
Um,
I breathe into it for a certain amount of time and it's again,
another program he created.
The company was around,
but he created the program that I'm supposed to do to put my body in a hypoxic
state for only a certain amount of time because you can overtrain yourself that
way as well to,
um,
to increase my capillaries,
increase the date of vasodilation and my veins as well as increase red blood,
increase increased red blood cells.